so first of all congratulations on this
show who encouraged you guys to get on
the show
my sister patricka did she encouraged us
to get on the show
she actually and and were there nerves
or were you guys just excited to just
play it all out on camera oh wow i think
we had a mixture of both nerves and
excitement yeah
i was more excited i think she was more
nervous yeah
i feel like out of my sister's i'm the
one who's always the most nervous um
so what can people expect from you both
this season
oh this season on extreme sisters you
can expect you're authentic
we're very authentic i mean we just who
we are we can't be anybody else
um lots of laughs because we have a lot
of humor in our family
yeah so you see lots of laughs lots of
great ideas that i come up with for us
she's the guru of ideas
and then you know that again the
authenticity of who we really are and
you know and we just love being
sisters yeah and have you guys always
been this close or is this something
that's gradually taken time to form
oh we've always been close but we really
got close after our brother
passed so um it it made us more
closer explosive closer and closer oh
and and how old were you when when that
happened
oh we were i don't know
yeah what was 34 when it happened okay
you know i completely understand that
you know growing up uh patrick's i know
that you were very protective
over your sister can you kind of
describe that bond
yes well it i just felt like it was my
duty to protect her
because i noticed people would treat us
different um the initial
meeting us you know you just noticed oh
they're twins but then when she would
stick her hand out to
you know shake hands and then people
would scatter
make fun of her so or feel awkward
around me
and you know and it still happens today
that people are more comfortable
you know talking to her she's
approachable and you know i'm
i i am kind of guarded now since i've
had to deal with that but you know other
than that you know it's
you know weird too yeah and definitely i
can see that
um you know patricia growing up what was
it like having that
undying support from your sister oh gosh
it was the best um
i mean i don't think i could have
survived without her you know
support um because i you know at one
point i was
you know had suicidal you know thoughts
because of it
so you know when you know you have a
sibling that loves you unconditionally
and
you know assures you that you know
you're you're beautiful just the way you
are and don't worry what other people
say
you know i mean you continue to live on
you get you know
life gets you know a little bit easier
i love that um what does your husband
think about your very close relationship
oh gosh well in the beginning it was
something that he couldn't understand
but you know now that he sees us
together he sees
you know what she brings you know in my
life he understands so it's you know
he's just open to it
he
yeah okay so look i have sisters i'm
very close with my sisters we talk all
the time but what makes you guys extreme
like what is it about you guys that
people are like
that's an intense relationship oh wow
well we we we can feel each other's pain
um i was in labor with my first child
and i didn't feel like she was like she
felt the pain i didn't feel
i called her and it was induced labor
yeah it was
you know we're just connected that way
and she couldn't be there i was so mad
and
but she felt the labor so she was like
she was there
i actually called her and tell her that
i said are you in labor because you know
i'm in so much pain
and i was at a nightclub
but i had to leave the nightclub because
i was
having contractions and i wasn't even
pregnant she was
in labor and she didn't even know it
until i called her
yeah that is so wild okay how long did
the contractions go on
for oh until they gave birth
yeah you know i have three kids i have
three sons so it happened twice
oh my goodness okay so what do your sons
think of your very close relationship
with your sister
you know but you know they understand
after a while you know they're like okay
when i'm gone if i leave they they're
always looking for me
calling we're coming back so you know
i'm a permanent
you know resident yeah to their home
oh i love that how old are your sons
what's what are the ages
uh my oldest is jeremiah he is 19
just turned 19 then i have logan he is
15
and ethan is 12. those are some
those are like teenage years those those
are those are good years
yes
i would want my sister to help out yes i
need her i need my sister
yeah i'm a disciplinary one because i
you know i keep going
like don't do this and she's like she's
over it so i have to stay around like
no they gotta do chores they got to work
out they gotta clean
she's like the drill sergeant walk the
dog
i love them so much okay so look i have
two sisters
i thought i was close with them not as
close as you guys what advice do you
have for me to get closer to my sisters
closer to your sister oh god um
spend more time quality time y'all make
sure that you call your sister
at least at least three times out of the
week
okay okay so i'm just you know and you
know
be social with your sister yeah and i
said channel in your sisters because
you know like i just think about her so
much and then
i just started to feel her and feel what
she's feeling if she's sad or if she's
happy
i could just feel it because i just
channel her in i know
i love that i love you too and last
question just to wrap things up you know
you have this idea of who you guys are
and then you know the cameras are in
front of you and they're they're you
know showing
your lives what's the number one thing
that surprised you the most about each
other during
this whole filming process
well for me i think what surprised me
was
learning getting my feelings out
actually being able to
release and open up and tell them how i
really truly
feel without worrying about hurting her
feelings or or her husband's feeling
ron's feeling
or anyone's feelings so i just was able
to release
yeah yeah i love that so it was a
therapeutic
kind of experience for you yeah
we absolutely need it
i cannot wait to see you both i i
you know you guys have so much charisma
i totally understand
why you're on tv can't wait to watch
your whole journey what a pleasure
getting to talk to you both
thank you so much
you